la guerra en ucrania deja 221 niños
muertos y más de 167 heridos según la
agencia ucraniana un informe con datos
de la fiscalía y los padres temen por el
futuro de sus hijos
elegimos esta escuela para nuestro hijo
de 6 años y elegimos una escuela donde
se supone que debe estudiar
él la escogió pero la vio destruida no
puede hablar es muy difícil
principalmente para los niños
como resultado de los bombardeos y
ataques diarios
548 instituciones educativas quedaron
destruidas también 40 instituciones
infantiles incluidas lugares de atención
médica escuelas de arte instalaciones
deportivas y bibliotecas de seguirnos en
el rodeo creyentes con jarrod si esto es
realmente un genocidio del pueblo
ucraniano porque los civiles sufren los
niños inocentes sufren los niños recién
nacidos también los niños de nuestra
escuela y de todo el país la dgt sigue
yo creí en la incertidumbre de las
infancias ucranianas se extiende más
allá del país decenas de niños de
orfanatos llegaron a londres después de
refugiarse unos días en polonia varias
organizaciones benéficas organizaron su
salida
finalmente hemos podido traer a 52
huérfanos de ucrania llevamos un par de
semanas trabajando un tubo en esto
unicef informó que cerca de 2 millones
de niños han abandonado ucrania desde el
inicio de la guerra mientras que 33
millones de menores se han desplazado
internamente